PIECE OF THE PARTIES PLAN TO
HOLD ON TO U.S. SENATE.
>> IT'S A SAD SITUATION FOR OUR
STATE.
>> ATTORNEY GENERAL JOSH HOLLY
WANTS TO SHOW VOTERS THAT HE IS
THE BEST CANDIDATE TO UNSEAT
VETERAN DEMOCRATIC
SENATOR CLAIRE McCASKILL THIS
FALL.
HOLLY'S OFFICE LED THE
INVESTIGATION INTO SPEESIX'S
CASE.
HE WROTE IN PART, I WILL HAVE MY
DAY IN COURT, I WILL CLEAR MY
NAME, AS ALL FAITHFUL PEOPLE
KNOW IN TIME COMES THE OF THE
TRUTH.
THIS AFTER PROSECUTORS DROPPED A
FELONY INVASION OF PRIVACY
CHARGE THIS WEEK OVER A PHOTO
THAT GREITENS REPORTEDLY SPOKE
OF A WOMAN WITH WHOM HE HAD A AN
AFFAIR.
>> THE WAY I LOOK AT IT AS, I
HAVE A JOB TO DO AS
ATTORNEY GENERAL, I HAVE A JOB
TO DO ON BEHALF OF THE PEOPLE OF
THE STATE AND I WILL DO MY JOB.
THE CHIPS WILL FALL WHERE THEY
MAY.
>> HOLLY, DUBBED AS THE GOLDEN
BOY, ONE PRESIDENT TRUMP'S
ENDORSEMENT AND TELLS FOX NEWS
HE'S DOING HIS BEST TO NAVIGATE
HIS WAY THROUGH A TOUGH TIME IN
MISSOURI REPUBLICAN POLITICS.
>> I FEEL FOR ALL THE FAMILIES
INVOLVED.
I HAVE A JOB TO DO AS
ATTORNEY GENERAL OF THE STATE
AND I WILL KEEP DOING MY JOB.
>> REPUBLICANS ARE CHOMPING AT
THE BIT.
>> I THINK YOU ARE NOW SEEING
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL START TO
DISTANCE HIMSELF FROM THE
GOVERNOR.
>> DESPITE THE DRAMA BETWEEN
HOLLY AND THE GOVERNOR, HOLLY'S
SENATE CAMPAIGN SEEMS TO BE
DOING OKAY.
A RECENT POLL SHOWS McCASKILL
AND HOLLY IN A VIRTUAL TIE.
McCASKILL HAS A WELL-FUNDED
WAR CHEST, WITH $11 MILLION CASH
ON HAND COMPARED TO HOLLY'S
2 MILLION.
IN A CRITICAL SENATE RACE THAT
MIGHT DETERMINE CONTROL OF THE
U.S. SENATE, IT'S YET TO BE SEEN
HOW MUCH OF A THORN THE
GOVERNOR'S DRAMA WILL BE IN
HOLLY'S SIDE.
>> THIS IS A NIGHTMARE SCENARIO
FOR REPUBLICANS IN THE STATE.
>> THE SPECIAL SESSION TO
CONSIDER GOVERNOR GREITENS'
IMPEACHMENT BEGINS TOMORROW AT